president donald trump is here in las
vegas continuing his campaign efforts
across the silver state
thank you so much for staying with us
here at 6 30. i'm sasha loftis
the president is holding a rally at
extreme manufacturing in henderson this
evening
8 news now reporter orc mana joins us
live there now with the latest details
orko
well sasha president donald trump is
expected to take the stage here in about
half an
hour and there are already thousands of
trump supporters here there isn't much
social distancing
and most people are not wearing masks as
you mentioned
we are at extreme manufacturing in
henderson and the city of henderson has
actually
just issued a compliance letter and a
verbal warning
to extreme manufacturing saying that
this event is in direct violation of
governor steve says lacks
copa 19 emergency directive gatherings
of more than 50 people
are not allowed and this rally
definitely passes that limit
henderson officials say large live
events must be approved by the nevada
department of business and industry
but the city has not been notified about
this rally being approved
now the city could find extreme
manufacturing up to 500
for each violation as well as suspend or
revoke its business license
still it seems the event is still going
on strong you can see
several supporters holding their signs
singing along to the songs in between
speakers here
and it seems president trump is still
set to appear soon
now earlier we heard some from some of
the president trump sanchez supporters
including former nevada attorney general
adam blacksalt and one of the trump
teams senior advisors kimberly gilfoy
so far we've heard a lot about governor
sisolak and how he has tried to shut
events like this one
down due to coven 19 violations but
supporters here
say they have the right to assemble and
make their voices heard
again we are expecting president donald
trump to take the stage here at extreme
manufacturing
in about half an hour or so we will be
live streaming that
on our website as well as our social
media channel
for now reporting live in henderson
tonight workout mana 8 news now